To build up this List Item,
we created a horizontal linear layout
with three children.
The first child is an image view.
The second child
is a vertical linear layout
composed of two text views
stacked on top of each other.
The third child is the same.
It's a vertical linear layout
composed of the two temperature text views
stacked on top of each other.
Now, you might be wondering
why we didn't use a relative layout.
Because that would give us
less layers of hierarchy.
Well, relative layouts are good
if you want to specify that one view
should be to the right of another,
or on top of another view.
Relative layouts are also good
if you want a view to be aligned
to the parent's left, top, right,
or bottom. But it's harder, in this case,
to center these two text views
within the vertical height
allocated by this image view. It's easier
with the linear layout here and here,
so if the image was any taller,
these two text views
would still stay vertically centered.
And this is what it looks like in
the Device Preview within Android Studio.
I want to point out one thing
about this horizontal linear layout,
which has three children: the image view,
the vertical linear layout,
and the other vertical linear layout.
The second child actually has
a width of 0DP but a weight of 1.
That means that any horizontal space
that's not taken up by other children
will be distributed among views
that have assigned weights.
So, if we look at this third child,
it has a width of wrap_content
and a weight of 0.
If we gave it a weight of 1,
then it would stretch out like this.
Basically, the icon is a fixed width,
and then the remaining horizontal space
is divided among these two children.
Since they both have a weight 1,
it's distributed equally.
But if you look at the wire frames,
these temperature views are actually
aligned to the right. So, all we need
is for the width to be wrap_content,
and for the weight to be 0.
Then, any remaining horizontal space
will be assigned to this middle element,
with a weight of 1.
And this is the code for the XML layout.
We have a linear layout
in horizontal orientation.
The width is match_parent
to match the width of the screen,
and each list item has
wrap_content on its height.
But it does have a minimum height
at least of this attribute,
listPreferredItemHeight.
We specify gravity to be center_vertical
so that all of its children are
vertically centered within it.
We also specify a little bit of padding.
Inside of it, we add an ImageView,
which has wrap_content
for height and width,
and we specify the source
as this placeholder drawable.
Next, we have the vertical LinearLayout,
where the width is 0dp
and the weight is 1.
We specify a little bit of padding
between this view and the icon beside it.
Within the linear layout,
we have the date_textview
as well as the forecast_textview.
Beside that, we have another
vertical linear layout
with the high temperature_textview
and the low temperature_textview.
And that's it.